desde sus posiciones en la franja de
gaza las brigadas qassam el brazo armado
de hamás han lanzado al menos 1600
cohetes contra israel desde los primeros
choques entre palestinos e israelíes en
la mezquita de al aqsa en jerusalén este
pero jamás movimiento islámico que
gobierna en la franja de caza no
representa a todos los palestinos
de hecho políticamente los palestinos
están muy divididos fatal la otra fuerza
política compensa en la región se
enfrentó a hamás tras su victoria en las
elecciones de 2006 un combate que
terminó con la división de los
territorios palestinos a partir de 2007
hamas ostenta el poder en gaza y fatá en
cisjordania aunque si los dos grupos
comparten algo es la enemistad con
israel estado que no reconocen por lo
que en 2014 formaron temporalmente un
gobierno de unidad en su contra jamás ha
sido el blanco de varias campañas
militares israelíes a las que ha
sobrevivido fueron los primeros en abrir
fuego contra israél este mayo y aseguran
que seguirán defendiendo su causa
palestina como tierra santa
voy a datar la palabra
si se trata de responder a vuestra
agresión y reclamar la victoria para
nuestro pueblo y nuestras cantidades no
hay líneas rojas reglas sagradas de
compromiso ni cálculos completos
este jueves en plena lucha con israel el
grupo armado entero a varios de sus
militantes bajas que se suman a las de
decenas de civiles que han muerto en
este nuevo enfrentamiento que sacude la
franja de gaza y varias ciudades de
israel